Traducteur: Chloe Harrouet
Relecteur: Elisabeth Buffard
Bonsoir.
(Rires)
Je vous remercie de m'accueillir ce soir.
Merci de m'avoir invité
à participer à cette conférence.
Je suis Christian Guémy.
J'ai quarante ans.
Je suis artiste peintre.
Mais je suis plus connu
sous le nom de C215.
C'est mon pseudonyme, en fait,
car je peins dans la rue.
Je peins ce qu'on appelle du graffiti
ou du "street art".
Je peins au pochoir,
avec des bombes aérosols.
Je peins dans la rue.
Je peins en contexte.
Je peins sur des objets.
Je me déplace.
Je voyage.
Je vais dans des bidonvilles,
dans des situations architecturales
diverses, aux quatre coins de la planète.
J'ai fait de ce hobby,
-- cela fait peut-être
dix ans que je fais ça --
J'ai fait de ce hobby un métier
puisque j'expose, par ailleurs,
dans des galeries,
où je présente des objets
sur lesquels je peins.
J'expose dans des musées, j'ai des oeuvres
dans des collections publiques.
Je travaille pour les institutions.
Je réalise des commandes
pour des municipalités.
Voilà, j'ai fait de ce hobby une réalité.
Car le principe de mon oeuvre,
c'est la réalité.
Je travaille à partir de photographies,
puisque je fais essentiellement
des portraits :
des portraits humains,
des portraits animaliers.
Toutes mes oeuvres sont construites
le plus souvent sur des images réelles.
À partir de ces images et photographies,
je les transforme en pochoirs.
Avec ces pochoirs, je vais dans la rue.
Je peins.
Je reprends une autre photographie,
virtuelle, parce que numérique.
Et je la partage ensuite,
comme je l'ai fait dans la rue,
je la partage sur Internet.
Vous qui passez,
qui avez envie de prendre une photo,
vous reprenez une photo,
vous repartagez sur Internet.
Et on passe ainsi au virtuel,
du virtuel au réel.
C'est une boucle
et c'est un échantillonnage infini.
Il y a quelque temps,
j'ai été démarché,
d'une manière un peu originale,
par une entreprise,
une très, très grande entreprise,
par mail.
Elle m'a contacté pour intervenir
dans un cadre nouveau pour moi :
il s'agissait de réaliser des oeuvres
pour un jeu vidéo.
Donc de réaliser des dessins qui
puissent être intégrés dans un univers.
Cette entreprise, je la connaissais
comme ça, de nom,
parce que je ne joue pas aux jeux vidéos.
Je n'y joue plus depuis que j'ai...
Enfin depuis au moins vingt-cinq ans,
je ne joue plus aux jeux vidéo.
(Soupir)
Le temps passe !
Cette entreprise, au départ,
je ne me rendais pas compte
de l'importance de la proposition
qu'on me faisait.
Mais quand autour de moi, j'ai dit :
« Ils m'ont contacté... »,
et ce n'est pas n'importe qui,
c'est le troisième plus gros éditeur
de jeux vidéo au monde.
« .. ils m'ont contacté
pour participer à un jeu vidéo,
dans un univers virtuel,
je sais pas trop
ce qu'ils vont me demander. »
Tout mon entourage s'intéresse
aux jeux vidéo.
Ils ont dit : « C'est énorme,
il faut que tu te rendes
à ce rendez-vous. »
Donc je m'y suis rendu.
J'ai été à leur siège,
qui se trouve à Montreuil
dans une énorme tour.
J'ai monté quelques étages
par ascenseur, seul.
Je suis arrivé dans une grande salle,
j'étais encore seul.
Et des écrans sont descendus.
Il s'agissait
d'un entretien par visio-conférence.
(Rires)
Donc, je me suis installé.
Mes interlocuteurs me parlaient
en fait depuis le Canada.
C'est également une entreprise française,
dont le siège est en Bretagne,
elle a également des bureaux
et toute une industrie outre-Atlantique,
aux États-Unis
et essentiellement au Canada.
Donc mes interlocuteurs au Canada
m'ont expliqué,
parce que j'avais quelques a priori.
Je me suis dit : « Qu'est-ce
qu'ils vont me proposer ?
Faire un jeu vidéo de street art ?
Ou peut-être un jeu vidéo
où les gens devraient faire du C215 ?
Qu'est-ce qu'ils vont me proposer ? »
J'étais assez inquiet, je vous avoue.
Et je me suis installé confortablement
et ils m'ont convaincu.
Parce qu'ils m'ont expliqué :
« Voilà, M. Guémy, on suit votre travail
depuis un moment.
Il s'agit de vous proposer
de réaliser des œuvres,
qui seraient intégrées
en temps que fresques
dans un univers architectural
en trois dimensions
d'un village qui se trouverait en Asie.
On vous confierait des visuels.
Vous les transformeriez en œuvres d'art
et nous les intégrerions dans le jeu.
Pourquoi vous ?
Parce que vous êtes portraitiste,
que vous réalisez des portraits
d'humains mais aussi d'animaux,
or les animaux ont une place
toute particulière dans le jeu.
Parce que vous manipulez la couleur
avec une certaine expérience.
(J'aime les couleurs fortes)
et que vous avez beaucoup voyagé
de par le monde, notamment en Asie. »
Et là, ils m'ont fait défiler
des photos des œuvres,
que j'avais laissées derrière moi
à New Dehli, en Inde en 2008.
Ils m'ont dit :
« Voilà, pour ces 4 raisons,
vous êtes l'artiste qu'on aimerait
pouvoir obtenir
pour intégrer des fresques dans notre jeu
dont le scénario se passe en Asie,
dans un village qui s'appelle Kyrat,
où un dictateur local,
un narcotrafiquant...
un narcotrafiquant
opprime toute une population locale.
Le joueur vient dans le jeu
et parmi les choses
qu'il doit découvrir ou entreprendre
dans le village,
il devra découvrir les fresques
que vous aurez laissées,
puisque vous êtes supposé
être passé dans le village auparavant. »
J'ai trouvé que c'était un scénario
qui était convaincant,
puisqu'il n'y avait, en aucun cas,
une caricature de mon travail.
Il s'agissait réellement de me faire
réaliser dans le virtuel,
les choses que j'ai l'habitude
de réaliser dans le réel.
Et là, l'aventure -- j'ai accepté,
c'était rémunérateur mais pas tant que ça.
C'était surtout une expérience.
J'ai accepté et la démarche
a commencé entre nous.
Ils m'ont demandé d'ouvrir une boîte,
sur leur compte, sur leur serveur,
avec des codes secrets.
Chaque fois qu'ils me contacteraient,
ils m'enverraient un mail
sur ma boîte personnelle pour m'informer
d'aller sur la boîte secrète.
(Rires)
Et là, il fallait que je m'empresse,
parce que souvent pour les documents,
il y avait un délai très court
pour les récupérer.
Donc il fallait que je m'empresse
d'aller récupérer le document,
de donner mes appréciations
sur le visuel qui m'était proposé,
et nous avions convenu
que je réalise 16 œuvres :
9 personnages et 7 animaux, à la base,
qui devraient être intégrées dans le jeu.
On a validé progressivement, un par un,
tous les personnages et éléments
qu'ils me proposaient.
Donc, j'ai réalisé
un travail assez classique
où j'ai pu réaliser des animaux, colorés,
comme ils me l'ont demandé.
Là, on voit ici le personnage
principal du jeu, Pagan Min,
sur lequel j'ai passé beaucoup de temps.
Un animal comme celui-ci,
j'ai passé une semaine pour le réaliser,
parce que tout est réalisé au pochoir,
en technique mixte.
Voilà, des personnages.
Encore des personnages.
Une manière de travailler
tout à fait traditionnelle pour moi,
puisqu'en fait ce sont des photos
que je découpe
pour créer des gabarits,
au travers desquels je peins :
c'est la technique du pochoir.
Tout ce qu'il y a de plus traditionnel.
Tout ce qu'il y a de plus basique.
Tout ce qu'il y a de plus réel.
Et au fur et à mesure que je réalisais
les œuvres, par mail, bien sûr,
je leur envoyais
une première vue sur l’œuvre.
Je dois avouer que même si j'avais
l'a priori de travailler avec une équipe,
qui est quand même...
ce sont de grands professionnels du design
et du gaming , je me suis dit,
qu'ils seraient sourcilleux
ou qu'ils allaient
avoir beaucoup d'exigences.
Ils ont été formidables.
Ils ne m'ont jamais vraiment mis
la pression, ni sur la qualité...
Ils trouvaient chacune de mes oeuvres
très qualitative.
Donc, j'en suis content.
.. ni sur la qualité, ni sur
aucun autre domaine, ils m'ont embêté.
D'ailleurs, je peux dire avec étonnement :
je pensais tomber sur une mécanique
un petit peu froide et huilée.
À un moment, car c'est un chantier
qui a duré un an et demi,
ils ont disparu pendant trois mois.
Plus de nouvelles, je retournais souvent
sur ma boîte secrète.
(Rires)
Ils appellent ça un "mandat".
On dit "commission" en anglais,
une "commande" en français.
Au Canada, on dit un "mandat".
Donc je me suis dit : « Peut-être
que j'ai perdu mon mandat ? »
Mais non, ils étaient juste occupés
à un tas d'autre choses.
Parce que ces jeux vidéo, aujourd'hui,
c'est comme l'industrie du cinéma.
Ça mobilise des équipes faramineuses,
aussi bien pour la virtualité
que la scénarisation, tous les éléments.
Il y a des musiciens qui sont attelés
pour la bande originale, etc.
On est dans des super-productions,
dans lesquelles,
mes oeuvres ne sont
qu'un tout petit élément,
sinon un bonus pour les joueurs,
à découvrir dans l'évolution du jeu.
Donc, j'ai fait parvenir tous les visuels,
les uns après les autres.
La veille de rendre le travail définitif,
tout était si professionnellement mené,
qu'ils se sont aperçus
qu'il manquait une illustration.
Donc, j'ai travaillé en précipitation.
On a envoyé tout ça.
Je pensais que j'allais rencontrer
une équipe de photographe
de cette entreprise.
On m'a envoyé
un photographe professionnel.
Si bien que les photos
sont parties au Canada
et je n'ai rencontré personne.
(Soupir)
Voilà comment ça s'est passé.
Or, il y a deux mois maintenant,
on m'a proposé de participer
à une exposition à la Fondation EDF,
sur l'innovation dans le street art.
Je me suis dit :
« Ça serait quand même le moment
de présenter ce qui a été fait
entre cette entreprise
et ma petite activité artistique. »
Car je pense qu'il s'agit
d'un phénomène assez innovant.
Donc, on a sollicité cette entreprise
pour qu'ils nous envoient un peu en avance
le résultat de l'intégration
de mes œuvres dans leur jeu,
puisqu'il était question qu'ils intègrent
eux-mêmes les œuvres dans le jeu.
Pas comme je le ferais dans la réalité
mais pour avoir du sens dans le jeu
et ses différentes étapes.
Et c'est ainsi que j'ai pu découvrir,
comme vous le découvrez, la vidéo
qui présente mes œuvres
dans l'univers virtuel de cette ville
qui s'appelle Kyrat
et où les joueurs peuvent évoluer,
trucider à foison,
se faire écraser par des éléphants,
dévorer par des léopards,
consommer par un tigre,
croiser des personnages
tous plus étonnants les uns que les autres
parce que moi je ne connais pas encore
réellement ce jeu vidéo.
Je n'y joue pas
et je dois bien vous avouer,
que ce n'est pas vraiment
le type d'activité à laquelle je me livre.
Mais je vais, tout comme vous,
si vous le souhaitez, découvrir un peu
ces œuvres dans cet univers,
bientôt,
puisque le jeu est sorti
la semaine dernière.
Il s'appelle Far Cry 4
et je remercie la société Ubisoft
de m'avoir offert cette opportunité.
Ainsi j'ai pu repartir dans ma réalité
avec mes petits dessins,
sans jamais avoir rencontré personne.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)